a very common debate I get into with my
friends is regarding the artistic
integrity of working on a film most of
the time is directing but often it comes
up a lot with writers to the artistic
integrity of the writer the director or
even the actor of what of your work on a
studio film and I personally believe
that that when you work for a studio
film which could be an absolutely
phenomenal thing I hope to do it in the
future but you're ultimately an employee
you're an employee you're not the money
person you are creating a product that
needs to generate income so your
artistic integrity is only as good it's
only as valuable as the money people
deem it is and it's ultimately their
liability it's ultimately their
responsibility to make the decisions of
the merit of your artistic vision or
skill or whatever you're bringing to it
so the whole argument about directors
should have final cut and you know
actors performances shouldn't get cut
and all this kind of and writers
complain about it all the time how their
script was rewritten and all this
garbage I'm just like if you're an
employee that's the rule of the game
that's the American capitalistic
entrepreneurial business model you're no
different than the dude on the assembly
line at Chrysler or GM you got to make
that door the way they make that door
even people at Apple they're under the
leadership of the CEO or whoever they
may come up with a great idea but
ultimately the buck stops with the money
people so that's why if you really want
that you got any clumps independently
you